pues moscú ha amanecido esta mañana
fortificada las medidas de seguridad son
mucho más importantes que las que se
adoptaron en las movilizaciones de el
pasado fin de semana por siete
estaciones de metro del centro que
estaban cerradas y ahora mismo nos están
llegando informaciones de que se van
cerrando nuevas estaciones de metro para
contener las protestas también se han
prohibido la venta de alcohol en los
distritos del centro donde supuestamente
se iban a llevar a cabo estas
manifestaciones que son ilegales no
tienen permiso de las autoridades y por
eso los que las han convocado las están
cambiando de emplazamiento a cada
momento y es difícil saber a qué lugar
se dirigen en cada momento se vigila
muchísimo a los transeúntes incluso se
han cortado accesos también para
peatones en algunas vías principales del
centro de la capital rusa no se veía
algo así desde las protestas por el
regreso de vladimir putin al kremlin en
el año 2012
saber cuál es la situación legal de de
navalny y de su círculo más cercano en
este momento
se ha rechazado la apelación y de
momento está en prisión hasta el próximo
día 15 aunque el día 2 de febrero
deberíamos saber algo porque ya hay una
vista judicial para saber si tiene que
cumplir en prisión esa condena
suspendida que estaba cumpliendo hasta
la fecha y que amenaza con volver a
meterle en la cárcel durante los últimos
días se ha detenido a sus más
importantes colaboradores muchos de
ellos están ahora mismo en arresto
domiciliario en comunicados para que no
puedan contribuir a difundir estas
manifestaciones mientras van llegando
cifras de detenciones en este momento
más de 1000 personas arrestadas en las
protestas con aval y en todo el país